it's nice to put the three-piece suit
see people that i haven't just seen in
so many years is wonderful yeah
absolutely you know you were talking
about waiting but it's not really when
we see you
like first of all that epic arrival that
you had come on tom that's fun come on
that was fun there's only one of those
guys and here he comes
okay question is where are you piloting
the helicopter not today i do fly that
helicopter but not today i didn't fly it
no that was a nice dismount you got out
that was a good strike kept the props
rolling you don't want to you know you
want to wait for that rotor i did love
though when you got out you went
straight to the fans and you took time
to really acknowledge everybody that was
here it's fun you know but i want to
acknowledge everyone i mean this is
quite a moment it's been 36 years for
this film the fans have been asking for
it all around the world and
people here i'm just looking going i
just can't believe this moment's here
and the actors i kept telling it's
coming
and i kept having to push the film off
another year another year and i just
said look it's
we're gonna have a great time when this
opens we're gonna wait and we're gonna
deliver it for the theaters it's gonna
be very exciting time for everyone you
know joe was telling me that it was kind
of hard to get you to step back in that
jacket and and become maverick again
because it's so special to you and
because it holds such a special place
too
everything had to be right it had to be
absolutely perfect and as i said 36
years people have wanted to do it and i
did a lot of research throughout the
years and thought about different
stories and what we could do and
technically developing
you know
different cameras and systems on how how
do we approach aerial photography how do
we put the audience in the seat of the
fighter pilot
from american made to fall out mchugh
and i were talking about a joke for 10
years
and the stories weren't right and then
it finally got to the point where look
at that
so everyone's asking it's got to be
right
it's got to be right yeah absolutely do
you remember that moment where you
realized that maverick was an iconic
character in film
you know when we were making it i knew
it was going to be quite a moment i
remember when i when you know you can't
anticipate decades later
but
i knew it was there was something very
special about it the same way when i was
making risky business there was just
something unique about that character
and and i think the world and the
characters and the same thing with top
gunner was that next level and
working with simpson brookheimer and
tony
being in that room you know they were
asking me to make that movie about a
year
and
i just remember sitting down like this
is going to be very special when i
really got in there with him but to be
you know you can't anticipate
what's going to happen i put everything
i have and every movie i make and but
who think 36 years later
you know and with these kids over there
i was like i don't know we're aching
we're gonna disappoint them you know
like i remember when i started to do i'm
like i know but
it was it's daunting yeah you know what
and and there's not one person in this
movie and joe too and everyone that
didn't that wasn't sweating bullets and
i said you know what if you're not
sweating bullets making this film you
shouldn't be on this movie you know
absolutely you know there were so many
beautiful moments in the film that i
loved um but i think the most beautiful
were the scenes with you and val and to
me i was telling the other cat your
other cast mates that i didn't feel like
that was acting number one i just felt
like that was two men having a really
beautiful moment who had such a journey
together
i felt that way when we sat down we
started talking about
the film together and just looking at
each other you know in the first one i
really
rallied hard for him to make the movie
and because i wanted him in the film
he's such a
tremendous actor and to have him play
that character and finally tony we were
like tony you just got to go tony scott
the director
you just got to go and tackle this guy
because i was like you val you got to
make this movie you know it was like
it's going to be you're going to be
amazing
and
and the kind of talent that he has
and you see that scene it's very special
this is very special yeah i think the
way you all handled the scenes with him
was just beautiful it really really was
beautiful yeah he's beautiful yeah
absolutely um you know maverick of
course is is a guy that pushes the
limits he always goes like you say go to
the line he goes right over the line
i'm saying just a little bit if i'm
being honest i see a little bit of that
in tom cruise
little bush
what the hell
good morning aviators what made you know
also that you had to go get gaga for
this song that you knew that was was who
needed to sing this title
i mean she wrote the score she was a
heartbeat it was something we were in
the middle of i'm very grateful to her
because hans you know i mean i hired him
first and rain man back in the day in
days of thunder we've made many films
together very talented and harold
faltermeyer's music's in the film also
and there's just there's an underlying
theme that we needed and and it was a
moment for all of us when she
she came in and sent the song and i
called her i was like
you just
you're amazing thank you this is this is
our movie it was it was as if she was
over there
and these two worlds just collided it
was a magical moment for all of us and
working with her on and she's just look
i have such admiration for her
you know she's
i once saw her concert uh jazz concert
and this enormously talented so it's not
just a song
when people see the movie her themes are
the heartbeat an emotional heartbeat of
this film well it definitely is that now
real quick before i let you go tarzan
was telling me he's in mission
impossible seven with you and he said we
ain't ready
we're not even close to being ready
so what can we expect from these next
two missions
it's off it's crazy it's great it's it's
epic it's
the cast is incredible the story is
just the scale in every way it's
it's it's really it's i can't wait for
it
it's very
rich the movie very rich the story
[Music]
you